روسيا ارسلت لايران اسلحه ومعدات امريكيه
وغربيه استولت عليها في اوكرانيا منها
انظمه
هذا ما نقلته محطه سي ان ان عمن سمتها
مصادر مطلعه
هو من احدث الصواريخ الامريكيه الصنع
المضاده للطائرات والمروحيات والمسيرات
يحقق ستينجر نظام دفاع جوي في الجبهات
الاماميه ويستخدم في دعم المراحل الاولى
من عمليات القوات المحموله جوا اما جافلين
فهي صواريخ مضاده للدروع تعتمد في مسيرها
بعد الاطلاق مسيره الرمح اي تطير بعد
اطلاقها الى الاعلى ثم تسقط عموديا على
الهدف وهو ما قد يعزز من قدره القتال
الميدانيه
ومن ثم فان حصول ايران على نماذج من
الصاروخين قد يصب في خانه تعزيز دفاعاتها
الجويه والميدانيه بحسب صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز التي كشفت ايضا عن معلومات مفادها
ان طهران تستعد لتسلم مقاتلات السخوي خمسه
لتعلن طهران اتمام الصفقه بحسب وكاله
تسنيم بالتوازي مع ذلك سربت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ما قالت انها صور اقمار صناعيه تظهر
قاعده عسكريه جويه ايرانيه وما يمكن ان
تكون طائره سخوي لكن لماذا يخشى الغرب
وقوع اسلحه امريكيه بيد ايران الجواب يكمن
في توسع التعاون العسكري الروسي الايراني
تحالف يقول عنه مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز انه يتحرك
بسرعه كبيره في اتجاه خطير للغايه في
الوقت الحالي
تحرك قد يتضمن تبادلا في مجال التصنيع
العسكري بين طهران وموسكو والهندسه
العكسيه اي اعاده انتاج اسلحه غربيه في
مصانع عسكريه محليه
فصحيفه تتحدث عن مضاعفه ايران الدعم
العسكريه لروسيا في سلسله من الصفقات
الجديده التي يمكن ان تعزز من ترسانتها من
الاسلحه وتعتبر مسيرات شاهد من ابرز
الاسلحه التي يتهم الغرب طهران بارسالها
الى موسكو بينما توفر هذه الصفقات لطهران
شرايين دفاعيه جديده وفقا للصحيفه وقد
تكون من بينها انظمه اس 3400
[موسيقى]